last time we talked about op-amps and
the fact that they allowed us to
abstract away certain components of a
circuit and sample particular voltages
from a circuit and then modify those
voltages as we would like in an LTI
fashion today I'd like to talk to you
about some other interesting things that
fall out of the fact that we're only
dealing with LTI systems in particular
of Thevenin and Norton equivalents and
superposition Thevenin Norton
equivalents is the idea that if you have
a very complex circuit but it's still a
LTI circuit you can express it using a
linear curve and superposition is the
idea that because you're also dealing
with LTI components if you're trying to
solve a circuit you can take the
individual contributions of independent
sources to that circuit and sum them in
order to find out either the total
current flowing through a particular
component or the total voltage drop
across a particular component at this
point I'll walk you through both
7:8 Norton equivalents is an important
concept in that you may have a very
complicated circuit and you don't really
want to talk about the entire
complicated circuit you just want to
sample the voltage drop or current in a
very particular location because we're
dealing with LTI systems we can actually
express that particular sample as its
relationship between I and V and
possibly whatever resistive component is
associated with the voltage drop across
that sample we can solve for this curve
by looking at the location that we're
sampling and finding the open circuit
voltage associated with that position or
if we were to leave the two terminals
from where we're sampling open what is
the voltage drop across that section of
our circuit that's the point right here
where the current flowing through the
system is zero and there's a given
voltage associated with it likewise if
we want to find the other intercept we
can close we can close though to those
two terminals by running a wire across
them and then look at the current that
flows across that wire that's the closed
circuit current
the slope is going to tell us about our
resistance if any if we're only dealing
with a voltage source or a current
scores then we're only going to be
dealing with a straight line once we've
solved for these values we tend to
express them either as the Thevenin
equivalent circuit or a Norton
equivalent circuit and you can convert
between the two let's walk through an
example here I've got a simple circuit
and I would like to find the Thevenin
equivalent of that circuit given that
I'm sampling from above this resistor
and below this resistor the first thing
that I'm going to do is find the open
circuit voltage or if I were sampling
from this point to this point what is
the voltage drop across this section of
the circuit well I've got 36 volts
there's 12 ohms of resistance in the
section that I'm sampling and there's 6
ohms of resistance outside the section
that I'm sampling so two-thirds of my
total voltage drop across this voltage
divider is going to be accounted for
inside my feminine equivalent circuit so
my v'n equivalent voltage is 24 volts
now I want to go after the short-circuit
current if I were to draw a wire from
this terminal to this terminal I'm
curious what this value would be as a
consequence of connecting these two
terminals these resistors are going to
be completely bypassed we don't actually
have to drop any voltage or fluent or
put any current through these resistors
because there's actually an infinitely
easier way for the current to go in this
case we're just going to follow Ohm's
law 36 divided by six is six amperes but
because of the directionality on this
short circuit current current in this
system is going to flow in this
direction so our short circuit current
is actually negative six amperes
that just leaves our th once again we're
going to rely on Ohm's law if we divide
our voltage by our current you can't
have a negative resistance we're
actually going to divide by the negative
of this we'll get out four arms let's do
it again this time with a slightly
different sample point and find the
Norton equivalent of our circuit so if
I'm only sampling across the 9 ohm
resistor I personally still solve for
the Thevenin equivalent voltage first
because I think it's easiest I'll just
make note of it over here the voltage
drop across this resistor is determined
by the fact that this is a simple
voltage regulator the other resistors in
this circuit sum to 9 volts or 9 ohms so
the voltage drop across this resistor is
going to represent half of the total
voltage in our circuit that's 18 volts
the short-circuit current associated
with connecting these two terminals is
36 volts divided by the sum of these two
resistors once again we're going to end
up by passing this resistor entirely
because think about it this way if there
was a resistor across here with zero
resistance all the current would sink
through it or it would represent the
location for which infinite current
would flow
36 divided by 9 is 4 and because we're
flowing in the opposite direction we're
going to say this is negative 4 amperes
in this orientation the Norton
equivalent amperage is actually the
negative of this value you sometimes see
the arrow pointing downwards
this preserves our property of
short-circuit current if this was
short-circuited ISC would still be
negative for EM fears and our Vth if our
V th was the voltage drop across these
two points ha
I haven't solved for R th yet there are
a few ways to do this but I'm going to
use B th and I n
eighteen over four we can reduce it to 9
over 2
and if I were to solve back out for the
voltage drop across this resistor just
as a consequence of I Norton I would get
18 volts which is also the Thevenin
equivalent voltage for the circuit that
covers Thevenin and Norton equivalents
I'm going to talk about superposition
really quickly superposition is yet
another circuit solving strategy it
falls out as a consequence of only
working with LTI components and it means
that in order to solve for a given
component current or a component voltage
you can actually find it by taking the
linear combination of every contribution
as a consequence of independent sources
what do I mean don't I say that well if
you have a circuit like this and you
might recognize it from the nvcc
lecture earlier you can actually express
it as a linear combination of just the
voltage source and just the current
source note when I remove the current
source I end up with no connection
because if you have zero current flowing
through system it's the same as if the
you know connection has been removed
note that when I remove the voltage
source I no longer have a voltage drop
across that connection but I maintain
the connection if in this example I was
just looking for I 1 I 1 would be the
linear combination of the contribution
of i1 in this particular circuit plus i1
in this particular circuit so this is
the expression that I'm looking for
in the first circuit I'm just going to
use V over IR or V equals IR and I'm
going to have three amperes in this
direction
in this circuit
I'm actually going to have to do a
current you know use a current divider
identify that I have five parts total to
distribute among these two branches
identify that this side is going to get
the inverse of this sides contribution
to the total parts or this side is going
to get the proportion of parts
equivalent to this sites contribution
and vice versa but this side is a side
that I'm interested in and so two fifths
of the total current flowing through
this current divider is going to end up
in this branch two-fifths of 10 is 4
it's in the opposite direction of this
current flow so I'm actually going to
contribute negative 4 amperes from this
subcircuit
this should match the results from the
MVCC lecture that's my superfast
coverage of superposition and also
Thevenin and Norton equivalents next
time we're going to start a whole new
module